ala welcome back to St Louis welcome
back to grest tour yeah it's it's been a
while we saw you in grest tour of course
you played in Grand swis you appeared
here there but let's say what what
you've been doing for five months
basically like four five months since CA
I played Croatia it was in July yes now
we're on no it's November it's November
okay October so two months I didn't play
in the middle yeah and let's say during
the summer yeah I was watching World Cup
CH and uh I was working on my chest and
um summer I didn't want to miss summer
that's I didn't want to spend one months
in aeran for summer where did you spend
this months I Been Everywhere Spain um
it was cool times wow sounds great who
are some of your chess idols and um how
they influenced your chess career yeah
um all I always said is I tried to learn
from all the world champions all of them
are great but Magnus is probably because
when I started playing chesse he became
world champion so it was 2013 years yes
and I started 2013 so it was always his
name there and we were trying to learn
from him so it would be a lie if I say
nothing you're definitely one of the
let's say the best players of this
generation but whom do you see also like
you know um really promising young CH
players in the world right now yeah um
all the Indians are scary to play and
the these Five Guys from India are
really talented name them please because
there are so many yeah I think GES
prananda
Iasi I I forgot probably names now all
of them are very good like each
tournament one of them will go up it
doesn't matter one of them will qualify
or will win so um they are very talented
so and usani players also they are very
good I do you consider to study
somewhere in any University uh I was
thinking today like I was eating this
Chick-fil-A today in the university and
I felt like it's easier when going to
study than chess because should be less
um nervous stress because you don't lose
to anyone you just go to the test you
read it and pass so it's it's cool Vibe
but I think I will get bored of it
that's also the problem which university
would you study if you had a chance um
I don't know I I like I like to be
lawyer because it's it will help me to
also and I think lawyer probably law
study yeah I studied law you see it
helped me with inter okay loresa thank
you so much and all the best of luck in
the tournaments thank
[Music]
you